yes sir Janice why don't you send a
little boy in right away he'll see you
now and here near Apogee we gimbal the
engine to exert a torque that executes a
pitch over maneuver to flip the rocket
by 180 degrees well that's very
impressive
thank you very much for taking the time
not done oh sorry
needless to say we use a PID controller
to minimize the dispersions to the
landing site anything else yes I'd like
a glass of water it's time to take my
sander in there quite a while well the
topic is science he can be a real chatty
patty for me too hey someday somebody's
gonna write a book about Sheldon don't
you want there to be a chapter about how
loving and supportive you two were
doesn't matter I reading it this is
groundbreaking work thank you and and I
thought you might want to apologize well
why you tried to shut me up with a patch
well I give those to everyone and you
have to understand Sheldon that while
your math is theoretically correct we
don't have the technical capability to
execute it so I'm ahead of my time
wait it would appear so all right call
me when you catch up
[Music]
for the first time
SpaceX have successfully landed its
Falcon 9 rocket on a drone ship in the
Atlantic Ocean
SpaceX founder Elon Musk called the
event an incredible milestone in the
history of space send him in
[Music]
you